area 15 the local immersive
entertainment complex has a new
experience to check out
rocky theis is showing us around what's
being called america's
most exceptional grocery store we are
exploring the
interesting world i could say about mega
mart here at area 15 and i've already
found some you know household
necessities like
cabbage and lettuce sandals flip-flops
yeah i hope they're your size they're
going to look really quiet
you have these in a ten and a half
possibly oh definitely yeah i'm sure we
do
yeah and you know if you need help
figuring that out we've got a kiosk so
explain that
oh so the kiosk you'll have your omega
access card
and anytime you want to learn more about
what's happening here learn more about
omegamar
its parent company dram corp you just
simply boop and you will have
your employee id activated
you guys have thought of everything
seriously you you've even thought of
outdoor
recreation not recreation
in omegamart's outdoor recreation
department we take the magic of the
outdoors
and we provide them in a comforting
place like
from your couch interesting i guess that
is relevant to the times right
yeah you can't leave the house you know
what take the outdoors and bring them
right on indoors
you know i'm very curious as to where
that leads and that takes me
to this area here which is a beautiful
garden of
of wonder yes yeah a bountiful garden
section with all sorts of botanicals of
your dreams or your waking self
you could imagine oh my god listen to
the sound effects in here too this is
beautiful so we're not only
oh my gosh we're not only in a grocery
store we are also in an
art installation clearly the outdoor
section really seems to have kind of
like turned inside out now we seem to be
traveling through some sort of
outward inside the garden world
okay you know what this is incredible
look at this
so you have to tell us why obviously
this is so area 15
why did you guys decide to bring it here
to las vegas
i think it was time it's time for vegas
is a city
of spectacle and we just wanted to
um provide a new context for that
something artist driven
something driven by story and curiosity
and but keep
the scale keep the ambition absolutely
and you are
a vegas native yes that's right born and
raised in vegas
we love that okay so tell people how to
come down and enjoy safely
well you can come down get your tickets
at meowwolf.com or omegamart.com
we do ask that everyone wear a mask at
all times
social distance whenever possible and
we're keeping a 25
capacity per the governor's orders all
right spencer you are
a creative genius thank you yes
it's been uh thank you for coming it's
been really nice to have you here
all right everybody stay curious and get
your tickets to a mega mart or
whatever world we are in right now i'll
send it back to you in the studio